hi everyone
this is professor m science and today i
want to discuss measurements in quantum
mechanics
with an emphasis on the mathematical
details
this is another one of our videos on
rigorous quantum mechanics
in the companion video link in the
description we explore the conceptual
understanding of measurements in quantum
mechanics
in that video we find it's impossible to
predict the precise outcome of a quantum
measurement all we can predict
is the likelihood of a given outcome
today we start with that conceptual
understanding
and then we expand it to explore the
mathematical subtleties associated with
for example
the generate eigenvalues or a continuous
rather than a discrete spectrum of
eigenvalues
let's go consider a physical quantity a
that in quantum mechanics is represented
by a hermitian operator a
called an observable we call the
observable
a to keep the discussion general but for
concreteness you can think of this as
say the energy or the position of a
particle
this observable a obeys an eigenvalue
equation as shown here
where lambda n are the eigenvalues and u
n the eigenstates
in the companion video on measurements
we introduce postulate 4
that tells us that when we measure a in
a system in state
psi then the outcome of that measurement
is an eigenvalue lambda n
of the operator a and i will get that
result with probability
given by this expression
we can find an alternative form for this
probability if we write the state psi
in the basis of eigenstates u n of the
operator a as usual
and the expansion coefficients c are
given by the projection of psi
onto the u basis states this means that
we can also write the probability
p of measuring eigenvalue lambda n as
absolute value of c
n squared in the companion video on
measurements we go into some detail
about the conceptual understanding of
this postulate so if you haven't seen
that video yet i recommend that you do
that first
and come back to this video afterwards
what we want to do in this video
is to unpack some of the mathematical
details of postulate4
they don't affect the conceptual
understanding of the postulate but are
useful for calculations
the main point is that when writing
postulate fall we're implicitly making a
number of assumptions
the first is that the state psi is
normalized
the second is that we're assuming that
the eigenvalues form a non-degenerate
spectrum
and the third is that the eigenvalues
form a discrete spectrum
what we'll do in this video is to
investigate what happens when we relax
these assumptions
and how we then have to update postulate
4 accordingly
let's start with normalization postulate
4
tells us the probability p associated
with every possible outcome of the
measurement
however when we measure a we will get
some outcome
so this means that the sum over all
probabilities should add to 1.
so is this the case let's calculate the
norm
psi psi of the state of our system we
can then write both bra and ket
in the u basis as usual
we can move the sum over m to the
beginning and we rearrange the
expression to get this
the bracket here is delta n m because
the u stays from an orthonormal basis
and this means that we can easily
perform the sum over m and we end up
with a single sum over
n of the absolute value squared of cn
looking at the probability up here from
postulate 4
we see that this is simply equal to sum
over n of the probability of measuring
eigenvalue lambda n
so what does this mean if the state psi
is normalized then we correctly get that
the sum over the probabilities of all
possible outcomes gives one
however if psi is not normalized but
instead this bracket is equal to some
other value
n then the probabilities as written in
postulate 4
don't add up to 1. to ensure that they
do add up to 1
we need to modify the probability and
rescale it by the normalization n
we can also replace the norm by the
bracket of psi with itself
and we get this final expression
so this is telling us that we can
generalize postulate 4
to the case where the state side of the
system is not normalized
if we use this expression here
with this more general expression we
have just the right for the probability
of measuring lambda n
we can now clarify a point that we first
made in the video on eigenvalues and
eigenstates
let our system be in state psi then the
probability of measuring lambda n when
our system is in state psi is given by
this expression we just derived
in this expression i have written this
sub index here to emphasize the fact
that the state of the system
is psi now let's construct a new ket psi
prime equal to r e to the power i theta
times psi
where r is a real number psi prime is
related to psi by changing its length by
a factor r
and its phase by an angle theta the
argument we made in the video on
eigenvalues in diagonal states
was that quantum mechanics is not
affected by such changes
and that psi and psi prime lead to the
same physics
we're now in a position to confirm this
by checking that the outcome of a
measurement
is the same whether we use the state psi
or the state
psi prime the probability of obtaining
eigenvalue lambda n
when the system is in state psi prime is
given by this expression
and again i emphasize that this
corresponds to the system in state
psi prime with this sub-index
now let's rewrite psi prime in terms of
psi and in doing this remember that we
need to take the complex conjugate when
we were with brass in dual space
in the denominator this exponential
cancels with this exponential
so this term is r squared in the
numerator
the absolute value squared of these two
terms is simply r squared
this means that this r squared cancels
with this other r squared
and overall we get this expression
comparing this result with this result
we see that the probability of measuring
lambda n when the system is in state
psi is equal to the probability of
measuring lambda n
when the system is in state psi prime
this confirms that predictions in
quantum mechanics are
independent of a scaling and the phase
change in our state
we next want to look at what happens
when we have degenerate
eigenvalues if lambda n is a degenerate
eigenvalue
then the eigenvalue equation at the top
here needs to be updated
to a acting on u and i equals lambda n
u n i where i runs from 1 to g n
we have already encountered this
eigenvalue equation for the general
eigenvalues lambda n in the video on
eigenvalues and eigenstates
it is telling us that there are gn
eigenstates that share the same
eigenvalue
and these g and different eigenstates
are labeled by the index i
you'll remember that the eigenstates
associated with the degenerate
eigenvalue lambda n
span a g n dimensional subspace of state
space
and we can always make linear
combinations of these eigen states to
get equally valid but alternative bases
exploiting this fact we can always
choose these eigenstates to form an
orthonormal basis
and we can therefore expand the state
psi of our system in the basis of
eigenstates of a
in this expansion i have explicitly
separated the sum into two terms
one over the distinct eigenvalues
labeled by n
and then the other over i taking into
account the degeneracies of a given
eigenvalue
this also means that the expansion
coefficients c now have an extra i index
and this of course follows from the fact
that the expansion coefficients are
given by the projection of the state psi
onto the u and i basis states
so in this case of degenerate
eigenvalues the probability of measuring
eigenvalue lambda n
as given by postulate 4 needs to be
updated to the sum
over the gn dimensional degenerate
subspace
and again we can rewrite this directly
in terms of the expansion coefficients
c
what i want to discuss next is how we
can rewrite the probability of the
outcome of a measurement in terms of a
projection operator
although this is a less familiar
expression than the one we have been
discussing so far
it is very convenient in some cases for
example when discussing the density
operator
so it is definitely worth going over it
remember from the video on projection
operators that we can write the operator
that projects onto the gn dimensional
subspace of state space
spanned by the basis states u and i as
pn
and it is given by the sum of the
corresponding subspace of the outer
products of the basis states
imagine that our system is in state psi
and then construct a new state
psi n as the projection of psi onto the
gn dimensional subspace associated with
eigenvalue lambda n
writing the explicit expression for the
projection operator we get this
this here is the usual expansion
coefficient c
so we can then rewrite the state psi n
like this
let's now consider the norm of psi n
using the expression we just got here we
can rewrite it in terms of a sum over i
and then a sum over j
as usual we can move the sum over j to
the beginning and we rearrange the
expression to get this
the base is orthonormal so this is delta
ij
and we can reduce the double sum to a
single sum over i of the absolute value
squared of cni
comparing this last expression with the
one up here we see that they are the
same
so this is simply the probability of
measuring eigenvalue lambda n
so what does this mean we can rewrite
the probability p
lambda n as equal to the norm of state
psi
n this in turn is given by the
projection of state
psi onto the gn dimensional subspace
associated with eigenvalue lambda n
projection operators are hermitian so
this is equal to pn
squared projection operators are also
idempotent
so pn squared is equal to pn and overall
this means that we can rewrite the
probability of a measurement outcome
as the expectation value of the
projection operator pn
onto the subspace spanned by the
eigenstates associated with the
eigenvalue that we're measuring
as i said earlier this is an expression
that is not so common
but if you want to see it in action
check out the video on the density
operator
the final thing i want to look at is
what happens when we have a continuous
eigenvalue spectrum in this case the
eigenvalue equation
is a v alpha equal to alpha v alpha
where the eigenvalue alpha is a
continuous variable
again we can expand the state psi in the
v alpha basis
and the expansion coefficients are still
given by the projection of psi
onto the basis states
from basic probability theory when we
have a continuous variable we need to
work with probability densities rather
than
absolute probabilities we therefore look
at the probability
of getting a measurement outcome in the
range between alpha
and alpha plus d alpha we call this
probability
d p alpha and it is equal to the
absolute value squared of v
alpha psi multiplied by d alpha
this in turn can be written as usual in
terms of the expansion coefficients like
this
so what does this mean for continuous
eigenvalues the
absolute value squared of the expansion
coefficients gives the probability
density
at that eigenvalue and to obtain actual
probabilities
we must first define a range of possible
outcomes say an infinitesimal range d
alpha
and then in this case multiply that
range by the probability density
if instead of an infinitesimal range we
have a finite range
then we integrate the probability
density over that range to get the total
probability
the most famous example of a continuous
variable is perhaps position
which leads to the position
representation restricting the
discussion to one dimension
a general state psi written in the
position representation
is given by this
the expansion coefficients are still
given by the usual expression
but in this case they are typically
written with the symbol psi
rather than the symbol c of course these
are nothing more than what we call the
wave function of the system
and you can find further details about
this in the corresponding video linked
in the description
what this discussion teaches us is that
when we work in the position
representation in terms of wave
functions
the absolute value squared of the wave
function gives the probability density
of finding the quantum particle at
position x and this of course is an
elementary result that many of you will
probably recognize
measurements in quantum mechanics
introduce the famous probabilistic
nature of this theory this leads to many
strange phenomena
but i would say this is also what makes
quantum theory so exciting to study
you can find many videos in the
description and in the channel where we
explore the weird consequences of
measurements
so do check them out and if you haven't
yet seen the companion video where we
explore the conceptual understanding of
quantum measurements go take a look
i think you'll find it really
interesting and as always
if you liked the video please subscribe